hello everyone this is the second game
from the Reykjavik rapid tournament of
2004 between Magnus Carlsen and Gary
Kasparov I accidentally said in my
previous video that it was an open
tournament but it was actually a
specially organized event where players
were invited to play here Gary Kasparov
actually received a large amount of
money just to appear at this event and I
will put a link in the description below
where you can check out some original
footage from this dis event and also a
short interview with Magnus Carlsen so
here a cross and opened up with d4 but
as you'll see in the video below Gary
Kasparov wasn't at the board he was late
for this game and I think he left called
left house and wait for like half an
hour before he showed up so when he
finally got to the board he played d5
cousin played c4 and we have c6 the Slav
defense by Kasparov Knight to f3 Knight
to f6 Knight to c3 e 6 Bishop to g5
Knight B to d7 III and Queen to a5
Kasparov goes for the Cambridge Springs
variation Knight B to d2 by Carlsen
Bishop to b4 and Queen to c2 Kasparov
castles we had Bishop to e2 and the
early e5 by Kasparov Carlsen castles he
ignores this and we have eight captures
on d4 and Knights to b3 now attacking
the Queen and only then preparing to
recapture the pawn on d4 Queen to b6 now
he capture Sundy for we have D captures
and C for Bishop captures on c4 and a 5
here Carlson pushes a 4 doesn't allow
Kasparov to put that pawn any further
and Queen to c7 we have rook to e1 and
here Kasparov played h6 and this is this
is very useful but also also an
interesting scenario would be maybe
something like Knight to g4
threatening h2 and after f4
maybe then h6 and after Bishop to h4
probably something like night to b6
kicking this Bishop after Bishop to d3
f5 and it's not a bad position for black
but
it doesn't really give you any idea how
to proceed to develop with black here so
although although it's it's a fine
position for black because part of
doesn't go for this he goes for h6 and
leaves his options open and it's a very
useful move as well you do give the King
some breathing space that's always
useful as you can see both of us pervs
nights are in a one in each other's away
so cuz para was a plan is probably
something like night to be six attacking
the bishop on c4 and after the bishop
retreats the h7 pawn will no longer be a
target so I guess we'll move in a lot of
ways across the place be sure to h4 and
we have Bishop to b6 by Kasparov now
pressuring the h2 pawn Crossin plays Age
3 and we have Knight to be six now and
here you can't I mean you can but
retreating with the Bishop to d3 isn't
really a good move here because now
Caspar has a knight F to d5 and here
this night is coming to b4 and it's
gonna be a very powerful piece even if
you exchange it once the other night is
then also coming to before so this would
be very good for Kasparov so after this
night to be 6 by Kasparov across and
played Bishop captures on f6 so we have
Knight captures on c4 and now Knight to
e4 if pawn captures Bishop then Queen
captures night and here Kasparov has to
entangle somehow here he decided to play
Bishop to h2 check King to h1 was played
and now Knight to d6 and this is a
pretty weird move after this move
Carlson definitely it gets the upper
hand probably after something like night
to b6 it's a it's it's an equal game
this Bishop is still attacked here this
Bishop could maybe be trapped here but
Kasparov goes for 9th to d6 and it's a
very interesting move so what do you do
here cross and accepts the challenge and
he plays King captures on h2 he's really
not afraid of any undiscovered checks
here cuz power plays at night characters
on e4 this comes with
scour check from the Queen Nancy seven
and now Bishop to e5 and here you don't
really have the option of moving the
Queen if you move the Queen then you
lose the piece Queen captures on e4 so
here Kasparov played knight Knight to d6
and here Carlson immediately attacks the
pin piece Queen to c5 now with a double
attack on the knight on d6 rook to the
eight you have to defend this
and now comes a very nice move b5 by
Carlsen the pawn is pinned you can't
capture because your queen would be
hanging on c7 here Queen to d7 is played
and now Knight to d4 as after the pawn
left the d4 square this is now on the
other and I Square for this night
controlling all of these squares and
here Kasparov played nice to f5 you
can't really capture if you capture upon
this is actually winning for white for
example if you capture then Causton
simply plays Queen captures night and
after Queen captures Bishop captures
rook captures rook to e8 check our King
has to move and now rook the c1 and
you're losing a piece okay you don't
have to lose a piece but you have to
give up at least the exchange would Rock
the c6 after Knight captures pawn
captures rook captures now you can play
Bishop to b7 but after rook captures
Bishop character since rook to a6 it's
completely winning position for white
you're winning the a5 pawn this is all
over
so after night to d4 Kasparov goes for
Knight to f5 and here Kasbah cousin
simple place D captures on c6 he wins a
pawn big characters on c6 and Knight
captures and c6 now Carson is attacking
the rook on d8 and also he's attacking
the pawn on a5 twice with the night with
the night and with the Queen rook to e8
by Kasparov and here cousin played rook
to d1 maybe he could have captured with
Knight captures on a5 but after
something like Bishop to a6 attacking
the rook on f1 rook moves and Queen
captures on a 4 because farro will grab
the a4 pawn and it's a very sharp
position
cousin didn't go for this after rook to
e8 he first played rook to d1 attacking
the Queen and we have a queen to e6
there was also an interesting move here
for example Bishop to c3 instead of this
rook to d1 if you play Bishop to c3 it
seems like now you have a triple attack
on the a5 pawn but here kasparov has
Queen to c7 check and after King moves
rook to e6 attacking the knight as the
knight is pinned
nothing is defending the Queen and c5
so after captures and Bishop captures
something like rook to see one now
preparing to capture the pawn you do
have Queen to f4 and now if white
captures Caspar would again capture the
a four point so definitely it's hard to
say how much of this course and had seen
but he decides to go for rook to d1
Queen to east by Kasparov and here
Carlsen played rook F to e 1 and instead
of this rook F to e 1 White is still
better here but there was there was a
very interesting move in this position
and I don't want you to find it this
move is it's I don't know it's not a
very easy move to find the move is
Bishop to c7 and the reason this is good
because in the previous variation I've
shown you you can attack the a5 pawn if
you play the Bishop to c3 but now that
the Queen has moved to east 6 now you
can play Bishop to c7 and now the Queen
no longer has the option of harassing
the King on this diagonal so now you do
have a triple attack on the a5 pawn and
after something like Queen to f6
attacking the B to pawn a you simply
push it to the fender to b3 and after
Bishop to e6 ok you do attack the b3
pawn you have this Knight captures an a5
simply grabbing the pawn and protecting
the b3 pawn and this is a very
interesting position that could have
come up on the board where Carlson is up
to passed pawns this a pond and the beep
on both our passports and that both ones
are well there is no way for because
part of to actually capture them so this
is a
position I wanted you to really enjoy
and maybe to study how would you
approach this position with white and
could you could you find the plan how to
convert the extra to past points into a
win as you do have to take a couple of
moves into account for example rook eat
the c8 pinning this bishop and could
white could white withstand this and you
know emerge victorious so this is the
position I just wanted you to see but
after Queen to e6 Coulson didn't play
this Bishop to c7 movie played rook F to
e1 kind of threatening some discoveries
after this Bishop moves Bishop to b7 now
there are no discoveries because Queen
captures on c6 is is the threat Knight
the d4 by Carlsen attacking the Queen
and Knight captures Queen captures and
now Queen to g6 protecting the g7 pawn
also threatening checkmate on g2 and
here in this position as you will see if
you check out the original footage
Carson had about three minutes on the
clock and Kasparov had almost 12 minutes
on the clock
so here Costin does have the option of
pushing f3 or maybe defending with
Bishop to g3 but let's say this is
played rook captures rook captures and
after Queen to c6 threatening checkmate
again f3 would have to be played and now
Queen to d5 Kasparov can easily offer a
trade of Queen's cross and is still up a
pawn but there are still opposite
colored bishops on the board but there
are still rooks on the board so it's not
not all that immediately
Grolsch so maybe maybe he could have
gone for this but with 3 minutes on the
clock it would be very hard to find any
kind of winning plan for white here so
after G's Queen to g6 Carlsen played
Queen to g4 defending checkmate and
offering a trade of Queens but now when
the Queen's come off the board Queen
captures H captures and Bishop to c6
going after the a4 pawn b3 defending now
f6 Bishop back to c3 rook captures rook
captures and Bishop to d5 attacking the
b3 pawn it's
very clear that Carson's extra pawn will
not will not matter that much in this
game Rock to be one defending we have
came to f7 knock King to g3 both players
improving the position of their Kings
rook to b8 now attacking the b3 pawn
calls and pushes before a captures
Bishop captures as if rook captures then
there will only be opposite color
bishops on the board this is a
completely drawn endgame so Carlsen
still tries to win this game even with
so little time on the clock and even
though he's playing against Gary
Kasparov he plays Bishop capture some
before Bishop to Bishop to c4 now a5
Bishop to e6 now blocking the past pawn
on a light square really not a lot
cousin can do here f3
King g6 now King f4 h5g capture skin
captures rook to h1 chick King g6 Bishop
to c5 rook Toby to King 2 G 3 rook the
rook 282 now attacking the pawn but
should be back to b6 King to f7 rooked
the c1 g5 now Carlsen checks on c7 King
to g6 and after rook to c6 check
Kasparov played Bishop to f1 and now
there is no way for you to defend the G
the G to pawn without moving the bishop
and have to remove the bishop you have
to give up the a5 pawn so here bishop to
have to was played by Carlsen as there
was no other move that defends the g2
pawn and Kasparov simply captured rook
captures a hidden captured rook in this
position they agreed to a draw but after
this point is captured it's both players
have rook two pawns and an opposite
colored bishop so this is this is a dead
draw so yeah that's the game
Carlson managed to draw draw against
Garry Kasparov so out of the three games
they played Kasparov has two wins and
the one game was drawn so not about the
not a bad deal for a thirteen-year-old
Carlsen
so that's the game I do hope you enjoyed
it and
I really do hope you will try and figure
out a winning plan in that position
where Carlson could have been up to
pawns but you know it's it's very hard
to figure out a plan there I would like
to thank Ruben Baraka and the david
whele for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here both of them will now be
Carlson versus Casper Oh from Reykjavik
2004 thank you all for watching and I
will see you soon